aujourd'hui on va parler d'une image
d'une statue choisi par catherine brice
et grâce à son travail
on va comprendre comment la monarchie
reste un élément central de l'histoire
de l'italie
[Musique]
je vais vous parler des moustaches du
premier roi d'italie victor emmanuel ii
plus précisément celle de sa statue qui
est placé sur un grand monument romain
le vittoriano place de venise à rome
ce monument parle de plein de choses il
représente l'unification de l'italie
la difficile l'implantation de ce jeune
état dans une capitale marqué depuis des
siècles par la papauté
il parle de remaniement urbanistique de
destruction d'édifices antico médiévaux
il parle de choix architecturaux de
parti pris artistique et parle de
politique de nation 2878 date de la mort
du roi victor emmanuel ii à 1921 année
de l'inauguration de la tombe du soldat
inconnu
juste en dessous de la statue le
monument et les projets ont évolué
aujourd'hui c'est un monument sur
lesquels des statuts hyper réaliste
côtoient des statuts symboliste c'est un
monument qui laisse passer des messages
politiques contradictoires sur trois
niveaux la patrie la nation italienne et
avec la tombe du soldat inconnu le
nationalisme mussolini a détesté ce
monument il a d'abord voulu le détruire
le fascisme révolutionnaire ne pouvait
tolérer un monument pareil mais il y
avait le soldat inconnu
et ça ça pose des problèmes et puis il y
avait le roi or la monarchie codirigeait
l'italie avec mussolini
ce qui nous ramène à l'élément central
du monument la statue du roi et ses
moustaches la statue du roi et
monumental pour son inauguration il ya
même un banquet de 12 personnes qui
s'est tenue dans le ventre du cheval et
quant aux moustaches du roi eh ben il
mesure 2 m à elle seule le roi est au
coeur du monument et avec lui la
monarchie italienne on ne peut pas
penser qu'on érige une statue dont les
moustaches mesure deux mètres à un
personnage à une institution qui n'a
aucune importance
une joue aucun rôle ce monument c'est
d'abord un monument dynastique
monarchique et c'est en réalisant tout
ça que catherine brice a remis au coeur
de sa recherche
la monarchie souvent oubliée discréditer
mais qui de la fin du 19e siècle jusqu
au fascisme ne peut pas être gommé de
l'histoire de l'italie
c'est ce que nous disent les moustache
frémissante de victor-emmanuel
merci à catherine brise qui nous a
permis de faire cette vidéo et à bientôt
sur une image une histoire
[Musique]